[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Awesome. Well,
happy Thursday,
everybody and welcome to
the Data Science Hangout.
Hope everyone's
having a great week.
It was so awesome to get to
meet so many of you at the
Posit conference in Chicago, and
so happy to be back with
everybody this week.
Hope you had a great time
with Robert last week. Thanks,
Robert, for covering for me.
I was out of the office and
got to go to France last week.
But for anybody who haven't
had the chance to meet yet,
I'm Rachael Dempsey.
And I'm the host of our
Data Science Hangout here and lead
customer marketing at Posit.
So this is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing,
and really just getting to hear
what's going on in the world of
data across all
different industries.
And so we're here every
Thursday at the same time, same
place. So if you're watching
this recording on YouTube
later, you can also add
it to your calendar.
If you ever want
to join us live,
it will be in the
details below. And James, I think,
that's where you first came
across the Hangouts as you were
watching a lot of
them on YouTube too.
- Yeah,
I've become a bit obsessed
with programming YouTube.
So I watch quite a lot
of programming tutorials,
programming like conference
talks online, and
play YouTube through
the television. So
it's quite a constant
stream for me.
- Love it. Well,
at the Hangout,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everybody.
So we love hearing from
everyone no matter your years
of experience,
titles, industry,
or languages that
you work into.
And so it's totally OK
for you to just listen in.
Maybe you're out for a walk,
or on your lunch break, or something.
But you can also jump in
and ask questions or provide your
own perspective
on certain topics.
So you can raise your
hand here on Zoom,
and I'll keep an eye out.
You can put questions in the
Zoom chat and just put a little
star next to it if it's something
that you want me to read out loud.
Otherwise,
I'll just call on you to
introduce yourself and add some
context. And then lastly,
we also have a Slido link,
where you can ask
questions anonymously too,
and our team will share that in
the chat in just a second here.
But with all that,
I am so excited to be joined
by my co-host today, James
Laird-Smith, data scientist at the Bank
of England. And James, I'd love
to kick things off by
having you introduce yourself and
share a little bit
about your role,
a little bit about
the work you do,
and also something you
like to do outside of work.
- Yeah, sure. Thanks for having
me. It's great to be on. So
like you introduced,
my name's James.
I am
a data scientist at the Bank of
England where I kind of work on
as like an internal data consultant.
So as we'll get on to--
the bank is quite big and so
the team of which I'm part,
we partner with different business
areas in order to try and
improve their data science
workflows and to bring a best
practice to the
work that they do.
I am also sort of separately--
I have a kind of specific
title of R business owner,
something which I'm not
sure exists in many places.
I hadn't heard about it
before I joined the bank.
But as part of that,
I am kind of the
businesses representative of the tool,
which means I attend
some meetings where some things
about are decided upon. And
there's also a component of
testing and people can ask more
about that if they like.
So I play quite a key role at,
very least, the language
but probably data science,
more broadly at the
Bank of England.
I should also maybe say
because, this is a frequent
source of misunderstanding,
the Bank of England is the UK's
central bank. So some people
think it's a retail
bank, but it's not.
So for those joining
from the United States,
it's much more akin to
the Federal Reserve.
People who are from elsewhere
know it as the Bank of
Australia, or the Bank of
Japan, or the European Central
Bank. So we're not a
retail bank. We're the
central bank for
the United Kingdom.
- Yeah, thank you for
that clarification too.
And I'll echo what Lisa said
in the chat that it's awesome that
you get to represent
the whole organization too. And
OK, what about something you like
to do outside of work too?
- Yes, I forgot. Very
good, very good. So
I think
people sometimes will
notice, is about my accent,
which is not something
I do outside of work.
The accent is the same at
work and outside of work, but
I happen to be a South African.
So I only came to the UK about
just under six years ago now,
and so I have perhaps a
slightly different perspective
as somebody who learned
programming overseas in Africa. And
that gives me a slightly
different perspective to some people.
I think the thing that
people most know me for,
though I don't do it
that much anymore,
is I used to be very involved
in competitive debating.
So at high school, at
university, for a long time, I
debated competitively.
Debating is something which is
mainly based out of schools and
universities. And so I don't
do it that much anymore,
but that's something I
dedicated quite a lot of free
time too. Not a lot of
data science overlap
with competitive debating.
But if you ask me about it,
I'll tell you about what
they have in common.
-
It's like we're going to have
to learn a little bit about
that. We might just
have to start there.
What are a few of the things
that they have in common,
or what lessons have you
learned from your experience debating?
- The answer is not much.
So like I said before,
it's a bit of a
stretch to say that
there's anything really
that much in common.
If I add a stretch,
I would say that even
in both roles, a lot of
debating is what we call impromptu,
so we only get a
short time to prepare,
but that makes us quite
good at like brainstorming.
So sometimes, when I
do some modeling, statistical modeling,
some of the activity is to
try and imagine what the forces
that are in play in your model
are, so what's really
happening in the real world?
And debating has some of that.
So when you scope
out an argument,
very often you
have to kind of get
hypothetical societies or hypothetical
people in your mind
to try and
understand what's going
on. So at a stretch,
I think that's probably
the similarity.
Of course,
on the skills level,
it's very useful to be able to
speak in front of people and to
have practice speaking
in front of people
because that has
obviously widespread use not just
in data science but in
lots of professional
capacities.
- Thank you.
Something I forgot to say up
front but wanted to add that in
case anybody's joining
for the first time,
there's always like a party
happening in the chat as well
and people sharing links and
resources with each other. So perfectly
OK and awesome to do that too.
So I just like to
remind people of that.
So if you have resources
you want to share,
feel free to use the
chat there for that too.
But James, when we were talking
a few weeks ago now, you
had mentioned to me that the bank
has 4,000 employees and I think close
to a thousand of them use R,
and I was just curious to
learn a little bit more of that
because that just seems like a
huge number of users for the
size of the work too.
- Yeah,
so I think the thing to
understand is I always think of
the Bank of England as
just a giant data factory.
So like we have a huge amount
of data going in and like a
broad set of data going in.
And of course, we
produce outputs
which get published and come
out in various other capacities.
So the weird thing is not
so much that we have a thousand
users, the thing is we
should have more actually.
So it's just that data is just
so central to basically every facet of
what the bank does
that actually a
lot of our aim is to try
and get more people into R and the
data science languages.
I have a brief breakdown which
I kind of prepared for this,
which I think is maybe
instructive on this point.
So the bank is hugely varied in
the kind of things that it does. So
there's like at
least one sort of
division of the bank, which is
a bit like an investment bank,
or a hedge fund,
or a mutual fund.
And their thing is a
bit like time series
and the usual things you would
think of like quantitative
finance and stuff like that.
But then there's another area of
the bank which is like an
academic department who's
primarily involved in
publishing papers and
research. And they
publish in Latech
and use quarter and
things like that.
There's also a huge amount of
the bank which is like just
operational. So we have
operational data. For example,
we collect data on banknotes.
So just the physical currency,
which that's an operational division of
the bank but also collect data.
And we use that data
to make decisions.
So my experience
is actually that--
and there's also areas of
the bank which are just
basically like a tech startup.
So that's just not untoward
something you might see at like
Google, or Facebook,
or something like that.
So all of those things
just mean that data is
ever present in our activities
and the work that we do.
So
it's not like we have too many.
We have too few users
despite the fact that we have
a thousand, or
something like that.
The other thing maybe to
note for people who might
not know is we actually have
good telemetry on this. So we
keep track of the number of
users of all our different tools.
And so it's not just like
we count downloads or something like that.
We have
fairly good knowledge of
exactly who uses what tools and
what they use them for. So
it's not an exact science. So
it's about a thousand users
over the course of a year
have used RStudio.
- Thank you for
that context too.
I see a few questions starting
to jump in here in the chat.
And Alan, I see you had
asked a question a bit ago.
Do you want to
jump in here first?
And sorry if my internet
just cut out for a second.
Is it OK? Does it sound OK now?
- Yeah
- OK.
But Alan, I'll
start reading it.
And if you want to
jump in after the question was--
you're the business champ for R,
is there an IT side owner as
well? And how do
you work together?
- Yes, absolutely. So the idea
is that we have a technology owner,
which is much like IT, and
we have a business owner. And yes,
we do absolutely work together.
So the technology owner,
unsurprisingly, is often
somebody from the
sysadmin type of role.
So people are responsible
for everybody's
tech infrastructure.
And
the business owner is designed
to be separate from that.
So it's designed to be
much more common that this person
would be a data scientist.
It's much more common that
this person would be working
day-to-day. So it's
a part of my role, but
it's not my entire role.
But yeah, we absolutely
work together, and
the technology owner.
And I sort of shoot each
other questions every day.
There are areas of overlap,
but we kind of need to
do different things.
The other thing which
the business owners also meant
to be kind of like champion.
So if there's something
wrong with the tool,
we have some administrators. Because
the bank is very big,
we have a team of
administrators.
And it's my job to raise issues
when they come about and to be
a kind of sounding board for
the users in general.
Well, at least, that's
how I interpret it.
I think the common practice is
sometimes have to walk a bit of
a tightrope, so
balancing different
users interests.
- Thank you.
Oh, Alan, we can hear you now.
- Laura, I see
you had a question
somewhat related as well.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah, so it's tagging on
to that. And it's related to,
when there's two
owners of one thing,
obviously there's never just--
like you said, there's
a lot of overlap.
And it sounds like you and
your IT owner have a good
partnership and you work
really well together.
But have you had to weigh--
there's ownership and then
there's territorialism.
And in every organization
I've ever worked at,
there are some people who
have just moved into the
territorialism, niche, and not like,
oh, that's an IT job,
that's not my job kind of
situation. Oh, that's a data side.
Besides,
it sounds like you have a
great relationship with your IT
person. I have an awesome
relationship with my IT person.
But how do you balance that
and ensure that you're meeting
business needs while not siloing?
- Yeah, so great
question. Mercifully,
I have been saved from
this particular quandary via the
same way I think you have.
A lot of our--
if there are tensions, they
tend to come in prioritizing,
where I have to
judge not like
whether something is important,
because oftentimes when anybody
comes to me with something,
it's very important for them.
So the
trade offs that I have to
make and pay attention to are what
the majority of users are
likely to find troublesome. And
that's often a judgment call.
And
thankfully,
have never needed to escalate
that the bank is very collegial
in that respect. But if so,
then there is a kind of a chain
of command. So there is my boss
and my boss's boss who are the
official people in charge.
So we do have a chain
of command as it were,
where if a tough decision
does need to be made,
then there is somebody who
is in charge of that.
On that same note,
a lot of it is individual,
the metric I try and use
to assess these things.
It's important to be mindful
of people who don't complain.
So people who have tried to
use a tool but have given up
because it's too difficult.
And I have to always be
aware that I don't hear from those
people because
they've given up.
And there's kind of a
selection bias there,
which is you don't hear
from the people who've given up.
And so one of the things
which I'm working on right now and
will continue to try and work
on is just getting package
installs correct.
So we have a set of
our own internal packages and usually
the process is quite
streamlined. But of course,
if there is a problem,
then that's a very big stumbling
block, especially for a
new user but can be for
an existing user.
So things like that I tend
to prioritize quite highly. And I will
up weight in terms
of their importance.
But
it's not the easiest thing to
do and requires judgment and experience.
- I see
Mike and Bill, you have
kind of similar questions.
You're asking around
cross-government
agency groups. Bill,
do you want to jump in here?
Do you want me to read it?
The question was
as part of a government agency,
is there a cross
governmental agency group perhaps loosely
affiliated with a focus on
art or other languages and perhaps
emerging technologies?
- We are trying.
So there are definitely people
who use R across the
government sector.
We also have an overlap of employees.
So some employees leave the
government sector or leave some
part of the government
sector, come to the bank,
and vice versa. And
so we have pretty good
relationships there.
Not quite to where it could
be. And there's definitely more
sharing that could be done and
that could also
extend to data sharing
and there are some agreements
for data sharing that exist.
But yeah, definitely
room to grow on that one.
- Mike,
did you have any follow up
question you want to add there? I
know your question was
similar too.
- Well, it was more that
within pharma industry.
We're engaging quite a lot
in discussions with the regulatory
agencies, FDA being a
good example, to define
what they want to see from
us when we interact with them.
I've been talking to one or
two people from different parts of
finance who then said, well,
it would be fantastic if
there was a similar discussion between
various bodies and
financial regulators to say,
are we giving you what
you want? Can we modernize this
and have that kind of
two-way discussion?
- Yes, so there's a couple
of avenues on this. And
there are
many lines of communication. And
a lot of them, truthfully,
do not cross my path because like
I said the bank being quite broad,
there'll be different areas of.
For example, insurance will
be different to banking.
The one thing we are trying
to do quite hard is modernize our
submissions. So what happens,
it's probably similar in
pharma, you will know.
But for in the financial
services and finance industry
in general, is a
lot of the time,
they need to be submissions
made to the bank on various
aspects of regulation. And
we put a lot of effort and
are still putting a lot of effort
into trying to make that as
seamless and
streamlined as possible.
And that's part of
lots of ongoing work.
- OK, Travis, on your question,
I might need a explanation
on the penny scheme from office
space from you.
- This is not a serious
question. [LAUGHS]
- I will say office space is
a great film, and I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed it immensely.
- I mean,
so the premise for those
that haven't seen it,
it's a group of
software engineers.
And they figure out a way to,
on top of every transaction
of which they're millions per day,
take off a fraction of a
penny, or something like that.
And they become very rich on
this scheme. And here, in the US,
a lot of us have to start
paying back our student loans
this month. So we're all
looking for our own penny
scheme. So if there's a way
to use R to help with that,
let's go.
- I will say something.
I think for those who
haven't watched office space, great film.
It's amazing how the
satirical element of
what it is like to work
in an office hasn't really changed
since that film
was made. So it's
very good if
somewhat horrifying watching,
it is good.
- Well, thank you. Thank
you for that explanation. There, Travis.
Marlene, I see you had
a question in the chat too.
You want to jump in?
- Oh, sure. Hello, everyone.
And Travis, as an aside,
I don't know why but my
mind went to the gag.
I can't remember what
movie I thought it is.
But the rotary phone where
they keep putting dimes in there.
So incrementally, somebody
doesn't notice the weight,
and all of a sudden, they
take all the dimes out.
And he just smacks
himself with the phone.
That's where my head went.
Sorry, welcome to my brain.
Hi, James, thanks for
joining us. My question,
which is kind of general, but
I'm always fascinated when I ask
folks in the data science
space this question,
what is a challenge that maybe
you faced and you may still be
encountering? You may
not have overcome it,
but you didn't see it coming.
I think we all kind of
have these, OK, we're ready to
gird our loins for the
inevitable battles between
departments and
governance issues,
sometimes it's political,
sometimes it's just
technical hurdles,
but what was something maybe
that kind of blindsided you
in the position that you're in?
- Yeah,
totally, I think this
definitely got to me. So
I spoke before about
just how big the bank is
and how much data work goes on.
And this had
an effect,
which I wasn't quite prepared
for but my colleagues were very
good in preparing me for.
Because part of this data
consulting work that we do,
we have a kind of a set
of practices that we adopt
that we have to upskill the
business area to maintain their own
tooling. So if they
develop a process,
they have to be responsible
for maintaining it.
And I came from a different
job, where it was like the data
scientists would build
and maintain the tools.
And I'm a maintainer at heart,
like I maintain a bunch of R
internal packages.
But my boss had to have a
serious word with me as he does
with like everybody. It says,
no, no, no, we can't maintain
it. And that's because
if we ever did,
we would so quickly
become overwhelmed with
that maintenance burden, that
we wouldn't be able
to do anything else.
We wouldn't be able
to do anything new.
And this is very
symptomatic of just
having a very big organization.
And I was totally not
prepared for this.
But I, wholeheartedly, now.
I'm on board with that.
And I think that
just speaks to,
you got to understand
your organization, your
organization's needs, and
it might not be the same.
So
to perform well in
different organizations often means some
things. Even sometimes if that
means stepping back and saying,
actually, I need to coach
somebody through this.
I can't just do it myself.
And so that was
a big one for me.
- Yeah, thank you
so much for that.
There's so much packed
into that by the way,
from a project management perspective
and scope creep, right? Because
I don't know about you guys,
but I can tell you from the
handful of people I have
interacted with on this call, you
guys are a bunch of fixers,
right? So we don't
like to leave things
unhandled or straggling.
And so we want to fix things,
and I think maintenance
is a huge part of that.
And so kind of drawing
clear cut boundaries is something
huge for a lot of us. So
anyway, thanks for sharing. I
appreciate your time.
- My pleasure.
- Tyler, I see you had
a question in the chat
a bit earlier. Do you
want to jump in here next?
- Yeah.
Thank you, James. I love the
insights, really helpful,
especially from the community here.
Nice to meet you all.
I think one of the things
that struck me most with your
thousand users, that I
wouldn't say I'm jealous.
But
as we've rolled out Posit
and some of the platforms wherever
in this like struggle to
get new users to adopt successfully
and happily to a new platform,
we love the things
we love about Posit.
A little bit more language
agnostic. It's a little bit more
open in that sense and a
little bit more flexible to the
communities that we're trying to serve
in analytics and data science, right?
But I'm just curious, how
do you guys handle that
conversion? Do you
mandate training?
How do you support
those new users?
We're forever trying
to make the [INAUDIBLE]
peoples happy.
How
do we really, in that space,
develop like the kind of
onboarding that can lead to
what you have demonstrated?
It's a very successful
kind of adoption.
That's a little less top down
and like here's a new platform
everybody on. We're just
taking all the old stuff away.
But more where you can get
people to come and really excel
and grow?
- Yeah, and the answer is that
there are no easy answers.
So a lot of the things
that you've touched on.
We do have dedicated training
and dedicated trainers.
And we have a schedule.
And we have excellent people
in charge of training who
forward that on to us.
Documentation also important, together
with that the kind of
offline asynchronous
resource that people can consult.
I will also say about
documentation in general.
Writing is a delicate art. So
I think one of the things that
makes a difference to me
is actually being given time to
write something properly, and
so to give the user like a
beginning to end experience that
is like reproducible for them.
That is underrated
in my experience.
So whenever I do sometimes
read documentation,
sometimes even my own,
which is not well written.
And it wasn't because the
person writing it is bad,
it's just because
writing is hard.
And writing in a way that
is clear and concise to the
broadest range of people is
an underrated skill that we
absolutely should
dedicate time to.
The third pillar of that is
just solving common problems as
much as possible.
So the holy grail
of package rollouts
as
platform rollouts, rather,
is just the one liner. Just,
can I solve this in one line?
Is this like a one line thing that
I can put in and I can get
the experience?
And we know that--
everybody on this call,
will know that it's
never as easy as that.
So if you read some
GitHub ReadMes, and the ReadMe is
two pages long and
requires some Linux dependencies, and
happens to works on
my machine syndrome,
and as much as you can get
away from that, is best.
We do that. I do that.
I try to do that by just
my particular solution
where I'm good at.
It's just to build R packages
around it. So we have
a range of R packages at
the bank which are specifically for
data access. So
we have x-system.
And this system has a way
of interacting with that
particular data. If it's
a database, or an API,
or something more bespoke,
just try and get it one line.
I just want one command that
I can run, and it
gets the user from
zero to connected.
And as much of that
you can give to users, the better.
Yeah,
never the easiest thing,
but as much as you can do,
you'll reap the benefits.
- Thank you.
I see a big discussion
happening in the chat under one
of Mike's questions. So I'm
going to come back to that. But
there was a Slido question
that someone asked anonymously.
And it was, how does the
bank manage reproducibility
of analysis? I guess,
this kind of touches on
what you were just talking about,
but especially with the
thousand users with varying
levels of proficiency.
- Yeah, totally, so
I think it's, again,
some training goes into this.
I really think that Posit's
tools that actually do this
incredibly well. The reason that R
Markdown doesn't really have.
You can't just like embed.
You can't just like reproduce
tiny bits of R Markdown.
It's really meant to be
like start to finish,
which basically means this is
something I didn't realize till
after many years of using it.
It's kind of like
reproducible by default.
And you actually have to
opt in to the non-reproducible bits.
And the same thing with
your Posit Connect and some others.
That element is
really good.
But otherwise,
the usual sorts of things that
people on this call will know
about, which is try and
make examples reproducible.
For example, in
the ref package.
A lot about culture and just
running things.
But also works in combination
with what I just said, which
is, it's easier if they
have easy data connections, right?
So if you're able to give
some people a data connection
package, then they can
do it, start to finish.
And I think a lot of
users are actually quite good at this.
A lot of users in my
experience are quite good at spotting, oh,
now I can run this app
because I've got
this data connection.
I'm not working with extracts.
And I think that the tooling
is a big part of that.
- Thank you.
Mike,
for the question and discussion
that's happening in the chat.
Do you mind jumping in to
kind of summarize the point for me?
I was trying to multitask
and figure out what it was.
And it was too hard.
- Yeah, that's kind of
exploded. Sorry about that.
So this is coming back
to James's point that
when you develop stuff, you
definitely don't want to own
that solution forever
or
maintain it because then that--
it's like if you
develop an R package
and you put it onto cran,
you are forever the person
who's going to have to make
live with updating
that forever.
Similarly within
the business I'm in,
we have a
kind of policy that I think
is similar to what James was
saying, where if
we're developing something,
it's worth the time to take to
develop it in a way that the
people we hand it off to
can maintain it themselves.
Maybe not necessarily
expand on it greatly,
but if there are bits,
they know where to tweak,
and they can get in there and
add a new variable or change
something from a to b quite readily.
I'm trying to get away from--
sometimes, what I see,
which is if someone comes
to you with a problem,
you solve that problem.
And you get it out the
door as fast as possible.
It is what it is. You just
deliver it and say, well, I'm done here.
Typically, if you rush at it,
then it's harder for you and
for anyone else to maintain in
the long term. So
if you take a little bit
longer and give them the right
solution that's easy for
everyone to maintain going forward,
it relieves the burden
on everyone. I think that's
what I can say.
- I can't help it, 100%
endorse all of that.
I only have an example to
add which is like, I think
these can be straightforward
things like function names.
So just take time to name
your functions. It's just
weird because it feels like
make work, but it's not
actually. It's
just
naming functions, and naming variables,
and stuff. It's just a
really important part of
someone else understanding it
in the future, and then
being able to audit it or
debug it in the future.
But yeah, 100% endorse.
- And sorry,
to kind of expand on
that, another example is
like markdown documents or reports
that you construct for someone,
if you make them parameterized and what
you do is that you feed in--
if you ingest like a YAML
file or something that drives that
parameterization, then they can always
expand it and add future
parameters and do all kinds
of clever things with it.
But it then means that you're
not locked into a given structure.
- Yeah, I understand.
-
I think we stay here for a few
more minutes on this topic given all the
comments there. But Donald,
I see you kind of asked
a question in that for,
I guess, help and
convincing others.
Do you want to jump in here?
Well, I can read it too
and feel free to jump in after.
But Donald had said
in that thread,
one of the biggest barriers
I face in building dashboards or
packages is convincing people
that the work is worth the
maintenance costs from either my
team or theirs, and would
love additional discussions around this
or any thoughts you have.
- Yeah, so
everything that I've kind of
said also applies to dashboards.
So dashboard design is just
also a hugely underrated skill and
takes
time and experience
to appreciate
when a good dashboard
is made well.
I have the same quandary,
which is I try and say to
managers or whomever I'm
trying to convince is,
it's much more preferable
to have a smaller number of
insights conveyed well and
continuously than to have a
great wodge of insights to
haphazardly
bandied together.
The reason that's not always
easy is there's always somebody
who wants their favorite chart.
And that's where you kind
of get the dashboard fatigue phenomenon,
where everybody wants to put
their own like bit on the
Christmas tree and eventually
the Christmas tree doesn't look
good or falls over.
And that's a hard thing.
And I think just manager
gumption to say that,
actually we don't do this.
We aren't going to
support like every chart.
We're not going to support
the broadest range of possible
visualizations for this thing. We
want to focus on core insights
and things that the average
person is trying to learn or
the average person is going
to want to know out of
your output,
whether it's a dashboard
or whether that's something else.
- Thank you.
A question I had for you is,
thinking about all the
different teams that I've
spoken with, probably thousands
of teams across six years,
what is your infrastructure look
like in terms of testing
and rolling out new products?
I know some teams might
have one server, some have
10 servers,
and they have their
own production and staging
environment. And
I was just curious
with supporting so many users,
what that looked like for you?
- Yeah,
so this is a bit of a
journey that the bank has been on. So
as we've sort of like grown
in a user base, we start to
see this a lot more of that
when we do roll out a new
version of our own. I'm kind
of now the person responsible for
testing it. But I can't test
the code of a thousand users.
For a start, like not everybody
is using version control, but we
are getting there.
But even if they were all
using version control,
we don't always have a
good catalog of that.
And that's part of
what I've tried to do,
it's to try and get
like a test bank.
So these are things which
absolutely should work. So these are
unit tests and
regression testing
and integration tests.
And our
philosophy is it's a good idea.
We try to get business in the
other areas of the bank to
contribute their code.
That's not always easy
because they're busy as well.
And
there's a couple of blockers
to being able to do that.
But I will also say
that it's, again,
something which just
takes time and energy.
So I invest quite a lot of
time in putting together our test suites now.
And it's hard in the short term but
pays a lot of dividends in the long term.
The other thing which is
a bit useful for that is,
so my area of focus is kind
of on our data warehouse,
so not everything in the bank
is based around its data warehouse,
there are parts that are
outside that but the data
warehouse is a good,
I want to say, forum for
that kind of testing because it is
where a lot of things can end
up or should end up. And so
I'm also partly responsible
for the tooling on the data
warehouse. So that's my way
of bringing it together.
It might be similar
for those on this call.
But just as much as possible,
try and get people on board
to test it themselves or ask them
to contribute it or reach
out and ask their permission to
grab it yourself.
Yeah, certainly
worthwhile doing.
- Thank you.
I guess,
I just think a lot about
the teams who maybe started out
with just a few users and
are starting to grow and need to
expand that infrastructure
and how do they know
what to do there, what
the next steps are.
I see lots of conversation
here, happening in the chat
here. I'm trying to
pull out the questions,
so feel free to just raise
your hand here if you have something
that wasn't really
answered yet.
But there's a lot of
discussion happening around, like dashboard
design. I think once
we mentioned like dashboard fatigue.
And Eric, I see you had a
shout out to one of the conference
workshops, if you
want to jump in here.
- Yeah,
I was privileged to be a
TA at David Granjon and Maya Gans's
workshop about effective design
principles for Shiny dashboards
at PositConf and highly
recommend, checking that out,
as well as David's book
on outstanding shiny user
interfaces. And with the
tooling that now is in Shiny
itself in particular
with bslib,
it's becoming a lot easier
to incorporate some of these best
practices of design without
being an official
UX designer with
years of training.
It's something that I think a
lot of people are able to pick
up on and hopefully avoid some
of the dashboard fatigue that can occur.
- Yeah, I'll say something
a bit about this.
I am constantly struck by
just how similar--
well,
I mean the name does
it justice, right?
This is design and
design is hard, right?
So design takes place in
all facets of life, often
underappreciated,
easy to ignore even when it's
done right just like all designers.
But I kind of feel of
the same way about dashboards that do
about good writing. So
good writing starts well, right?
The first sentence should
engage the reader in the same
way that the first thing
that the dashboard shows.
The most important thing
or something not necessarily
gripping but something which you
would hope would introduce the
rest of the concepts which
are to follow. Again, structure is
important. I mean, we're
very good, as humans well, I
guess because our education has
focused us on how to
structure text very well
because we get lots of training
on this insofar as we have,
structure headings,
citations, and
things like that.
And we don't really get it
for dashboards, but a lot of the
same things apply.
Notably, some exceptions too,
but I see them as very similar,
especially asking yourself
the question, or sorry,
answering the question
on behalf of the user.
What are you trying
to communicate to them?
What question do they have
that you're trying to answer?
And what goes along with that
is you don't want to answer
trivial questions. But you
also don't want to answer.
You don't want to
lead with a question,
which is impossibly
difficult to understand.
And all of that is design. And
we should have design focused,
teaching which I'm sure
that workshop that you mentioned
Eric was primed to do.
- Absolutely. And Ted,
I feel like there needs to be
a shout out to your comment here
in the chat here as well.
Where Ted said,
a good dashboard is often the
product of subtraction not
addition to.
And I see a lot of other
thoughts here shared on design.
Does anybody else
want to jump in?
- Yeah,
I mostly use subtraction
because I knew Libby was going
to take the bait.
But I think if there
is something to be said about
pairing things down and editing
and people don't really
think about that.
-
I'll give people a few more
seconds if anybody has anything
else they want to add
on the design topic. But James,
I think it would also be interesting
to hear a little bit more about
the
organization and how
you have yourself as the R
business owner for the business
representative and then you
have this tech representative.
And it just feels like
that would be a helpful,
I don't know, team to have
in many different companies.
So I was wondering like how
long has it been that way,
or did your team
kind of start that, or did
you have to advocate for that?
- No, so this definitely
predates me at the bank.
So it's more than
a few years now.
And I think
just sort of grown out of
an extending user base.
It's maybe worth mentioning that
we have this for a couple
of R tools now and some of
the tools we grouped together.
But Python certainly has its
own business owner and technology owner
and we have some other internal
tools which do that as well.
And arguably, we
will have some more
when the community inside the bank
grows to a large enough size.
I mean, I find it
a very healthy construct to
have with so many
users. And again,
I think if you took any
of those roles away,
you would detract from the
quality of service that
the users are able to
enjoy. But I didn't have it
at the previous place I worked.
I'm sure they have been
shouting out in the chat
but
if not, then they can
shout out now that
maybe other
organizations have it,
if maybe not under
the same names.
I see there's a question in
the chat about adopting new tools.
I don't know if somebody
wants to shout that out.
- Yeah, I think it was Marlene.
- Yeah, it's me again.
I'm just curious like
how
amenable or agile is your
team specifically about
adopting languages
tech, et cetera?
- Yeah, so I would say
that there's a balance and with
important work we
will facilitate.
So the one thing to bear
in mind is the bank is quite
sensitive about security. So
we have a policies on what
can be installed,
which I think is fairly common at
many organizations. And so we try and
balance the concerns of wanting
to adopt new technologies and
wanting to
be secure, but also not
to
adopt something too quickly.
And
part of the reason is that
sometimes you can get bitten on this.
So somebody develops a business
critical process in a language
that's not supported and
people will move on
to other roles and
perhaps leave the
bank. And there's
a maintenance burden,
which goes along with that,
which we have to be mindful of.
And those are the competing
concerns. And so I think
I'm on board with the idea that
we have to balance things.
So there is a bit of work
happening with Julia right now.
But
we haven't sort of
promoted it to fully
fledged support yet.
And then we might not.
- Yeah,
Libby,
I think you have asked a
question that was kind of in
line with what I was trying to
ask earlier and I didn't ask it
as great as you did. So I'd
love to have you jump in here
with your question around
R excellence hub.
- Yeah, so and I did get
an answer, which was great.
I've only ever lived
the experience of
you can't use these packages.
You can use these packages.
And the packages I want to use,
never being on the list
of packages that I can't use,
right? So I was always
sitting around wondering,
is there a land out there
where there's a dev environment or
where I can just use whatever
package I want and create a
case for, hey, I think we
should use this package is, hey,
I think we should put
this through some testing to make
sure that it's safe and
then put it on the list.
And it looks like I had
one answer saying yes.
I'm curious if anybody
else has. And James,
if you have any feedback
or experience with it?
- Simply, what I've said
before, we try and balance
these concerns as
much as we can.
- It's such a selfish
question. [CHUCKLES]
As a data end user, I see
lots of people like nodding.
But I also know that on
the regulatory end of it,
it's important to not just
let people use any package they
want in any version
they want. And
Mike's, like, no.
So I get it.
But that's a tough question,
right? How to balance that?
- I see,
Mayank, had shared
some thoughts there.
Do you want to jump in?
- Thank you, and thank
you for the great session
[INAUDIBLE]. So
we kind of had multiple
production servers based on
geographies. So we used
to work on reinsurance organization.
And due to data privacy issues
each geography in Europe or Asia,
so there would be eight
or nine different production servers
but there would be only one
dev environment and nobody would
really look at dev environment,
there would be oftentimes,
like a data scientist
like Ruby or myself,
would want to use something
out of the Shiny [INAUDIBLE]
So we would ask
them to go to dev,
play as much as
they would want to,
and then once we will
get the sign off,
we'll implement those in prod.
Also whenever it would come
up with new updates to their
products in terms of
[INAUDIBLE], we will first install
and we would have a
series of scripts to do
the testing of code based
deployments are working or am I
able to use ggplot and basic stuff.
Once we get a
report out of that,
we will then move everything
to prod, all the updates.
And we will do the same
regression testing again on
that, so that we are kind
of shielded from immediate
updates. And as
an organization,
we are able to give users
the latest and the best.
So that's how we use
dev prod service.
- I love that. Thank
you so much for sharing.
- Before jumping to
another question, James,
just want to make sure,
did you have anything else
you wanted to add there?
- No
- As we get
close to the top of the hour,
just a reminder, just anything
in the chat. I'm so sorry,
feel free to just raise your
hand to ask a question here too
or just copy it over it and
ask it again if that's OK.
Let me go
double check over
to Slido as well.
But one of the
people oriented questions I love
to ask James is about
career advice
that you've either
then given or have given.
And so, thinking back,
is there a piece of career
advice that really stands out
to you? So I would love to
hear it.
- Oh, that's a good question.
I think the thing that I--
it's
going to sound very
obvious, but it's just to
really get enjoyment
out of what you do.
I think that probably speaks to a
lot of people on the call given
your attendance here today.
But just being interested in
the subject matter that your
work is involved in is just
huge for your motivation and
your ability to continue with it.
So that's
really excellent. But I think,
it's not good career
advice perhaps,
but it's always just to
keep perspective about what your
career is and what
your job is and that
you should never be sort of
hamstrung or
bound to
a particular career or company or
anything like that. It's just to
assess as rationally as you
can the situation you're in and
where you want to be
and
to cash out, to
take time for yourself,
and to make sure
you have that balance of
the considerations that you care about,
which is not very exciting,
not very novel advice.
I think, again,
it's going to be super obvious
to the people on this call, but
if you do get a chance,
I do think programming
is transformative. So I mean,
on this call are probably
long past the stage where we
are surprised at the
power of programming.
But if you think back
to your past selves,
certainly back to my past self,
which is just the
ability to use code to
interact with the various parts
of your life or your work,
was definitely a
changing point for me.
And so I don't mind advising
people to take up code because
I know what code and software
has done for me, and
it happens to be a
reasonably good career
prospect at the same time.
And so what a fantastic thing for us
to be able to engage in something which
is both hugely interesting,
hugely rewarding,
and has good career
prospects along the way.
So not advice to anybody
watching this or maybe even to
people watching the stream, but
if you are asked about advice,
I think just learning to code
is such a phenomenal
life changing experience
that's worth emphasizing.
- Thank you for that.
Is there a specific story
that you'll share with people who
you're talking to who
are interested in learning,
like to show them that impact?
- Yeah, for sure. Well,
I'll tell you a bit about
my experience of learning.
So I grew up in South Africa,
and one of the things
that happens in South Africa,
it's changed a lot now. But
internet use in South
African is far removed from
what you might encounter
in the west, so
especially with the
availability of internet data.
And so what you'll get is,
it's changed quite a lot now,
but South Africans used to turn
off the data on their phone
because they were afraid of being
charged on their mobile plan because
internet was very expensive,
or it used to be
very expensive.
And so what I would do
is I would go to the university
library and I would find a
way to download YouTube videos. So I
listen to some talks on Python
and this was important for my studying,
but I downloaded them because I
knew it would be too expensive
to watch them all
in my flat at home even
though I'm, by South African
standards, very,
very well off. But
it wasn't worth it
from that perspective.
And so these demonstrations,
which were video recorded were
just like gold dust to me.
They were like something which I,
as somebody who lived
thousands of kilometers away,
could experience this world and
got insight into this world and
live demonstrations. And I'm
very, very grateful for that.
It changed my life. And
that's a story that I'll tell,
having to download those
YouTube videos. And of course,
you watch them on
repeat because you could never
download enough so I ended
up watching them quite a lot.
Now, of course, I have a
much better experience of
watching of watching YouTube
but I would also say that
kind of reinforces the notion of video.
So I know that some
conferences and some speakers
understandably don't want
to be video, but it is so,
so appreciated by people who cannot
be in the room with you.
And there are kids in other
parts of the world who will
watch that. Who will go out
of their way to watch that.
And you're always
speaking to them.
- So [INAUDIBLE]
I love that. Thank you so
much for sharing that James.
- My pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
- I know we have
two minutes left here.
And I realized, Eric,
I had missed one
of your questions from earlier.
If you want to jump in here
with one of the last questions?
- Yeah, I mean,
certainly, James,
you don't have to answer all
this fully in the time we have.
But just curious,
from your standpoint of all
the data you mentioned that you're
dealing with at the bank, are
there uses of R with other
novel technologies that
are enabling a lot more
speed or performance for your
data science teams as you're
crunching through this
vast amount of data?
- So yeah, in the
middle section,
there's definitely data table. So
data table is great. Data table
is slightly
underrated R technology. But
when you have something which
a lot of people try to take
out of the database and want to
work on really big data,
but they need the performance.
Also a lot of people, like
data table for its syntax.
So that's great.
A lot of the things--
so I guess we are now
just starting on this
journey like anybody of LOMS.
And so we have a hackathon
quite soon just to see the--
we're not using it in
earnest yet. There's
just a couple of
things that are being planned,
and we'll see what
comes out of that. Of
course, we do text mining.
So text mining,
the bank has a network of
agents across the country and
those agents report to us on--
they do interviews,
and they report to us on
the state of different
industries and businesses. And so
text mining is very, very
fruitful for be able to
extract insights from that.
So
like I said before,
it's hugely varied.
So the bank is very
data set hungry and
those are just some
of the ways that we
utilize R in particular.
- Awesome, thank you.
- Thank you so much, James,
for joining us today
and sharing your perspective.
It's a reminder to me too to
also say thank you to everybody who
ends up watching these Hangouts
on YouTube in the future as
well. I just want to say like,
you all are a part of
this community as well even if
you're not here
with us in the room.
Maybe you're watching on
YouTube and commenting and
sharing with others as well.
But a special thank you as
well to everybody here for all the
great questions today. I
had so much fun getting to meet
so many of you at the conference.
And also just wanted to say
like amazing job on all of the
conference talks.
It was so fun just like running
around to try and catch as many
of the Data Science
Hangout folks talks,
or whether you were
watching those virtually, or there,
in person, in Chicago.
So thanks, everybody,
for making this community what it
is and hope you all have a
great rest of the day.
- Thank you
- Bye, everybody.
- Good bye. bye.